thank you sir
welcome one and all to binge battle
presented by rotten tomatoes hey kids my
name is mark ellison whether you're
watching us on facebook on youtube
we're gonna have a good time today why
because we have two esteemed special
guests and we're gonna be debating
all things the mandalorian season one
season two remember before
in 2020 when we all just needed content
just to get us by
dude one division was a distant dream a
song in our heart we could barely hear
but we had
the mandalorian season one blew us away
and we said i can't wait for what's next
look at that cute little baby i wonder
what his name is and then the
mandalorian season two
you're talking about not going online
until you've seen the show
spoilers of plenty action of plenty old
characters returning some new favorites
emerging
and that's all we're going to talk about
today is the star wars show the
mandalorian on disney plus whether
you're joining us on
facebook on the rotten tomatoes facebook
page or the movie clips facebook page or
in the rotten tomatoes youtube feed
we're
we're international baby we're all over
the place and we're all in one place
right now
alongside myself i am thrilled to be
joined by
one of my dear friends you all know her
from all places
including e access hollywood and
everywhere in between
she is ash crossin ash how
are you is your dad still flying planes
yes he is but i don't work at access
hollywood mark i work at entertainment
no no you just got the gig they haven't
told me yet
okay well this is this is your coming
out party of course you work for e.t
and access hollywood that's just some
other channel that somebody else works
on we've been friends for so long
you know this information we haven't
seen each other this is the problem with
the pandemic it's like you hang out i
know you have a cute dog
and that dog is named uh dk and then he
got a dog named miles and that's all i
really know to this point about your
life
and i know that you're doing a lot
you're interviewing a lot of people
people
interviewing you and i'm so thrilled to
have you back on the show today
joining ash from e.t is
from sci-fi caitlyn bush and caitlin you
are so busy working over there at sci-fi
you were just in a meeting and you took
the courtesy to hop on over here to talk
things mandalorian it's got to be a
pretty good day for you so far
it's going really good i am so psyched
to be here i haven't had a chance to
talk
star wars with other people for a while
so i am
very ready to get into it this is a very
safe environment to talk star wars in
katelyn bush ash crossing i am merely
mark ellis and here's how binge battle
works is that there's going to be
possibly five rounds different topics of
debate
that feature scenes episodes characters
from the mandalorian season one
and two and you the viewer get the best
part because you get to determine who
won
each round and thus who wins today's
binge battle how do you vote it's very
simple you just go on that rotten
tomatoes
facebook yes the rotten tomatoes
facebook is where you're going to be
voting so let's say that ash is making a
killer argument about something
and you think she's winning this
particular round gonna hit that thumbs
up
that's the like button that is gonna be
ash's button throughout the duration of
the show
if you think caitlyn is just too good to
pass up and her argument holds water
with you
then you hit that heart that's the love
button as we say
caitlyn got the love but ash we love you
just as much i don't want you to feel
any lesser than because we gave you the
thumbs up and not the heart doesn't seem
like it
i think i'm just i think there's some
bias here i'm i'm
i'm sorry yeah yeah i feel like there's
too many tv
to remember she can take the like for a
day so
i'm going to be ushering you all through
all of this sort of fun stuff when it
comes to the mandalorian before we get
to that i want to let everybody have a
chance to get in and
get situated get their bearings so let
me just go way
way way back in the day starting with
you katelyn bush the first time you
heard of this galaxy far far away called
star wars
what was it what was the thing what was
your gateway into this
whole new world oh my god this is one of
my favorite things to talk about
uh star wars a new hope it was the first
movie that i remember watching
growing up as a kid my parents are huge
star wars fans as is my younger brother
and it's something that we really bonded
over and i've really been lucky to
have a career trajectory that's taken me
into this space where i get to talk
about it
all the time yeah ash you
have a similar trajectory where you're
on the red carpet you're interviewing
star wars but you're friends with these
i mean they
love that they're they light up when
they get to talk
to ash who's your favorite like who's
the best star wars personality out there
to
to interview um it's so hard because
there's so many people i love but
hands down it's it's john boyega he is
the best person to talk to
he always like brings the energy he's so
fun to be around and
he just always like remembers me and
remembers the last time we talk and you
know those little personal touches just
mean so much
that is awesome yeah john boyega seems
like a delight i would love to hang out
with famous people too
and i get to do that right now with ash
and katelyn so we're just about ready to
go
here um like i said it's gonna be five
rounds you're each gonna get a minute to
have your opening statement as to why
you feel this way about this particular
issue so
if for instance we were talking about
all of star wars and i said what's your
favorite star wars movie
i would correctly say return of the jedi
and then i'd have a minute to say
why it is even though i only need two
words we won and then
your counterparts gonna go for a minute
and then you get a 30 second rebuttal
back to your counterpart for 30 seconds
and that is when we're going to start
tabulating all the fan
votes so again get your finger on your
mouse clicker thingy
whatever computer you use i'm still
working with windows 95 and netscape
navigator
hit the like button if you think ash is
winning that round hit the love button
if you think caitlyn is winning that
particular round okay
ash kaitlyn the rules have been laid out
are we ready
for this epic binge battle set in a
galaxy far far away
let's do it
buy me a coke round number one
it's simple what's the best episode of
the mandalorian the best episode of two
quality seasons of content
the best episode god i hope you all
prepare for this in advance because now
i'm racking my brain thinking about all
the great episodes that i saw
over the last two years we go to ash
crossing
for her opening statement a minute long
and it starts now okay gosh this is so
hard okay there are so many near perfect
mandalorian episodes and i wanted to get
away from something that like
was a big moment like the dark saber
boba fett all those are great even luke
skywalker but
peyton reed took us to absolute star
wars church in chapter 16
the rescue i mean it had boba fett
bogatan fenekshan coast greed's car dude
they all teamed up some of the best
choreographed choreography we've seen in
the show
um we get that whole cool like dope jet
pack moment we also get that showdown
between moff gideon and dingerin that
was like
dark saber in live action which we've
been wanting to see
um and then we also get like the tension
building for next season we also have
the dark troopers let's not forget what
louis gardenson did
in this episode um just like i can't
wait to hit the clubs with that dark
trooper song
and then we hear the jedi that grosgu
heard the call to was freaking luke
skywalker spoilers hope you watched it
and then we get to see r2d2 and then of
course we have this emotional moment
the send-off between mando and the child
and what's gonna happen next i cried and
uh and then of course we get r2d2 and a
post-credits scene setting up
uh the next chapter the book of boba
fett so just dope from top to bottom
that's my that's my pick yeah that was
that was a fun episode to watch along
with
my brother virtually he's up in seattle
and we were both watching it along and
he was like two minutes ahead and so he
was texting me oh and x-wing just showed
up and i'm like all right
stop texting me i don't want to know
anymore so episode 16 the rescue
pretty good bar to set katelyn bush you
now have a minute for your response
oh boy so chapter 16 fantastic i was
going to do it originally but
i was re-watching and i have to pick
chapter 15
the believer which is i think everything
that star wars is about you get into
bill burr's character
he is the believer or maybe it's this
other guy
this uh this empirical old-school
believer who is trying to
bring back what was the empire that we
know eventually will become the first
order
it's the first time that we're really
setting up what's going to come
later down the line other than obviously
like you said
the end credit scene is going to have
boba fett that's great
but you're getting the gang back
together in chapter 15. i love
getting the gang back together montage
they're going in they're kicking ass
and then you come up to this very quiet
scene
you get den taking the helmet off which
is always a fun time
and then bill burr comes in to save his
butt
by just spouting off all of this
empirical knowledge that he knows
how could you not love just seeing
mando not know what to do just sitting
in silence because he doesn't know how
to emote
and then you have them turning on each
other and killing each other
and it's it's it is everything that star
wars
can be like it's it's emotional and it's
action-filled
if you told me when i was a kid like
okay mark in 2021 you're gonna be
talking star wars what do you hope to
hear about i'd probably say r2d2 luke
skywalker what do you not expect to hear
about
how great bill burr is but he is
tremendous
caitlyn spot on these are two of my
favorite episodes going at it right now
episode 15 for k1 episode 16 for ash
remember if you think caitlyn has the
right episode
as far as the best of all time so far
hit that love button for ash hit that
like button
ash you got 30 seconds to respond why is
the rescue better than the episode that
just preceded it
oh god this is so hard because i i love
that episode as well and uh but
i you know for me star wars is about the
emotion that like invokes in me and
those emotional moments and for me
chapter 16 was just so memorable in
terms of those amounts of moments so
it's like we see
you know uh when we see din and moff
gideon going at it in that lightsaber
battle
uh which wasn't lightsabers you know
what i mean though um
that was like i was like oh man like
i've been wanting to see this for a
while and then we
even like the music and the score that's
in this episode was just
so memorable to me and then of course
the luke skywalker my way as soon as we
saw the
x-wing i started bursting into tears
like a maniac
and i will never experience that again
so anytime i experience those like big
visceral moments for me
that that will stay with me forever you
knew you you knew as soon as that x-wing
pulled in you
you knew it was luke i there was a part
of me that was like
what if it's leia because we kind of
didn't know like where
she was at at that moment but i was like
it could be her that would be crazy
um but in my heart of hearts i knew it
was luke
you're you're a better watcher than i
because kate when i saw the x-wing point
i was like oh cool those other two
pilots that they ran into trapper's back
and then i saw the green lightsaber and
i was like oh okay
yeah maybe maybe this is something a
little more force
sensitive so okay that was a great 30
second rebuttal
caitlyn it's all on you tell me why the
believer is better than the rescue
so love love love the rescue obviously
but i think i also have to point out the
reference to operation sender uh
in the believer because then you get the
beginning of the end of the empire
which kind of resulted in the rise of
first uh order you get
ray sloane was a part of operation
cinder originally
eventually kind of kills the final plan
but not before the emperor causes
so much destruction and before palpatine
uh can interact his
final clone plan and also race low
eventually helps start the first order
with hux's dad
whose name is i think brendall
um but then of course bill burr and his
fellow soldiers and burning khan all of
the destruction that happened there
there's just so many references packed
into this tiny little
very emotional back and forth between
these two men
who have such opposite beliefs that i
can't not
just love it uh well if you do love
caitlyn's argument you're hitting that
love button for ash to win this round
you're hitting that like button going
into some fan comments here
david taylor is very excited about this
conversation
and he's willing to admit in a public
forum cried at groga's departure didn't
we all tear up
just a little bit uh maurice has a great
comment she says this is hard because
these are my two favorite episodes so
y'all really
tugging at the heartstrings with some of
these folks you know it's
it's so funny did y'all get caught up in
any of that when
when bill burr's character first
appeared in the mandalorian
everybody was freaking out that he still
had a boss in acts like we can't have
bostonians in space
we have british people why can't we have
boston i want a whole planet of boston
star wars am i wrong
i think that's the next disney plus
series yeah
i would totally think i'm excited about
obi-wan
okay but i i don't want to mess with the
cannon too much if that guy's doing any
more than crossword puzzles at the
mos iceland cantina i i don't i don't
know what we're doing
let the guy rest let the old hermit take
a nap i do have an answer
the votes are in they have been
tabulated and
i i'm looking at the comment i know how
hard it is i know how hard it is and to
echo mostly superheroes comment
we are holding our breath right now ash
crossing
is the winner of round number one the
luke skywalker r2d2
probably tugged at the heartstrings
including those of the hosts a little
too much even though i have no say in
i this even blame him because i would
have voted for that too
yeah it was uh pretty pretty special
moment you never know if you're gonna
get any more luke skywalker and you did
but i will say this
shouldn't have worked and it looks so
good uh it looks so good looks so good
here's my thing grosgu baby oda right
goes with luke and everybody's like oh
i'm glad he went with the
he didn't go with luke he was not on he
was not about luke skywalker
until r2d2 shows up and he's like oh
cool an arcade machine i'll go play with
that
that's why he got on the ship
in my opinion he's on that elevator
because of r2d2 once again
saving the galaxy so r2d2 may not
qualify to be a candidate in round
number two because our premise is the
best supporting
character our 2d2 maybe not enough
screen time to get that nod
so kaitlyn bush you find yourself
trailing one to nothing but plenty of
time to come back
and you get a minute to tell us who the
best supporting character in the
mandalorian is
okay so here's a spicy take i think my
favorite
best supporting character is frog lady
yeah who is introduced in season two as
we know
um she's my queen and her whole thing
is that she is on a mission to save her
family she is on a mission
to create the family that maybe she
never got to have we don't know too much
about her backstory other than the fact
that she's just going to look for her
frog husband whose name is actually just
frog husband frog man
get no other names for these feed these
creatures other than that and they don't
even try to make it an alien it's
literally just
it is a frog it leaps like a frog when
they're running away from all of the ice
spiders
and can you how can you not appreciate a
frog who just wants to relax
in a hot tub like with all of her little
eggs and then of course
because of frogly you get the whole
scene of
grogu the baby yoda eating with eggs
which
obviously blew up the internet which
caused a lot of people to call
like like murder kind of which was an
interesting debate to watch happen
across the internet um and we don't get
to be with her for very long but i think
she stole a lot of hearts
hey you know what that's that's the
internet for you because people were
probably eating their eggs
or their egg sandwich from starbucks as
they were criticizing
grogu for munching on some eggs that
were right there he didn't know the
difference
eat all the eggs you want just don't
take the last one we're trying to save a
species here so frog lady
an interesting maybe a little bit off
book choice but i think that's a solid
argument for caitlyn so click that love
button if you agree with her
ash crossin your best supporting
character
oh okay i'm going with ming na wen as
fenic shand
she is the most mysterious and
intriguing to me
and she does so much with so little
backstory like she's known for like
killing the top crime syndicates and
taking down the huts but
there was such a reaction to her in the
first season
just showing up and then getting killed
off in one episode like people were
pissed
i was furious personally but then she
comes back and we see her like team up
with boba fett
like he obviously respects the hell out
of her and they respect each other
and she helped mando rescue grogu and
major points there and all that um
but then she's also like currently like
co-ruling jabba's palace and i think she
has the most potential out of the
supporting characters in terms of her
future
because she's getting not one but two
spin-offs because don't forget she's
also going to be in the bad batch so
we're going to get a lot of fenix and in
our future so for me best supporting
character
this is the beauty of star wars because
you'll pick two characters that we had
never heard of
until the mandalorian so we're not
necessarily resting on our laurels
saying oh it was so cool to see
boba fett back it's so awesome to have
luke skywalker back in the mix
these are two new characters and they
had an emotional resonance with all of
us
so caitlin i'm going to give you 30 more
seconds to champion frogway
it's weird to put frog lady against ming
na wen but right that's your task
this is this is the the challenge which
i have i have presented to myself but
i think that i i love all of the
characters
in mandalorian who have this these
larger um
plots that are going on with them but
the ones that i'm really charmed by are
the ones who are kind of one-off
characters
the ones who we don't really get to be
with for very long but because the
writing of the show is so good
and the acting the animatronics of that
face is all so
fantastic you can't help but fall in
love with them and even though you don't
spend a lot of time with them you still
feel these emotions
and that's what all of these characters
from star wars are so good at doing is
they give you so little but you care so
much
i cared a lot about more than i thought
i would about frog lady and even her
little frog
zygote things little thingies
i feel like i'm hosting like a telethon
to help save frog lady if you care about
frog lady
as much as katelyn does then click that
love button
[Laughter]
but if you love the character that ash
cross has champion played by the
incredible mignon when
maybe hit that like button ash 30 more
seconds to tell us why that is the
button they should hit
yeah not to just like i'm just boosting
caitlyn a little bit but i think you can
argue that frog lady got the most
press out of either of these characters
uh
but i yeah the reason i didn't go um
with with frog lady was i think that
i just i don't think we're going to see
her again which is
like the antithesis of caitlin's
argument she has a great argument there
but i just think that fenech chan has so
much
future potential that i'm invested in
her going forward
i get it okay uh anthony alicia
is in the chat and says frog love is the
purest love
and it's true it was a beautiful moment
when they reunited
oh my god i feel that in my bones to
this day
again i love saying this you're clicking
like for ming not when
you're clicking love for frog lady
alex that's a question while we're
tabulating the votes no love for cobb
vance where where was cobb van that was
he in the conversation for y'all when
you're making your picture yeah
of course how could he not be yeah
timothy oliver
like that was some next level like
pulling from canon and dropping it back
in
yeah the the thing is the argument was
it wasn't who's the biggest space daddy
in all of the mandalorian right which
obviously so obviously would go to him
like
and is that a i have a feeling that's
going to be a category that pops out
that might be double overtime
daddy but you have to do it across all
the space franchises not just star wars
okay well look this the winner of this
round that we just had for best
supporting character it was a close one
caitlyn bush has tied it ladies and
gentlemen on the strength of frog lady
and i will tell you this i mean watching
watching when she was reunited with
her hubby and they got to like have
their family situation back they live in
a tiny studio apartment
i felt more emotion there than i did
re-watching the notebook which i had to
watch two nights ago for rotten tomatoes
is wrong
the podcast everybody should be
downloading so i champion
the frog people above kate uh
rachel mcadams and ryan gosling so
that's how much i care about frog love
anthony
your comment was right on caitlyn ties
it
it is one to one and now it goes back to
ash
from entertainment tonight e.t
for round three and that is the best
grogu
moment i mean come on we all love grogu
so many great moments including those
where he was maybe
trying to commit some sort of light
genocide ash crossing
a minute on the clock goes to you what
is the best baby yoda moment
okay there's so many good moments to
choose from because pretty much every
time he's on screen it's giftable but
i went with all the way back to chapter
two um when we see him use the force for
the very first time against
the mud horn which is about to like kill
the hell out of mando
because i think not only does it explain
the amount of power that grogu has and
like his use of the force
it also solidified his connection i
think with with amanda with den
at the time because he was so willing to
like exert himself i think he passes out
for like several days after this to
protect his
his father figure so there was just so
many layers to that moment also just
uh moments wise little big gorenson was
really pulling it out on that one too
that's another uh club bop for the
future but yeah
favorite moment yeah caitlyn so many
people were talking about that we're
obviously episode one of mandalorian the
first time we see the show it ends with
that little t is like wait it's a little
baby yoda and then
this this little thing do the use the
force it did the force trick
and you just wonder you've been around
50 years is this the first father fig
you've ever had in your life and now i'm
gonna go get emotional so while i have a
good cry for a minute
you let us know your best grogu moment
okay
that one was great ash i do have to
rebuff though with chapter nine which at
the opening
we see a another bounty hunter try to
take rogue away from amanda which we
all know that is a big no-no you do not
mess with
grogo and grogan just sits there
pretty calmly he's not really doing much
of anything and then
he gets him to trade uh
baby for his jet pack baby
runs across to him arms held wide
because he's finally reunited with his
dad and he's safe
which is absolutely adorable and then
mando launches
this butt wipe up into the sky
with his new jet pack and grogo enjoys
every second of it he loves the violence
he's
slowly turning into like his own bounty
hunter and he just is following in his
father's footsteps
um that's dangerous when you start
loving the violence that much and you're
force sensitive
there's a yeah there's i think there's a
history there
of people with violent tendencies and
force stuff i don't know though
it doesn't always work out well for the
galaxy or for them for their soul but
long way to go for grogu and we have a
long way to go in this matchup currently
one to one
and now ash crossing you get 30 more
seconds to tell us why
that first time we realized who exactly
baby yoda was is so important
this is so hard because i feel like
every girl moment could be the best
grogu moment just depending how you look
at it
uh but yeah for me again it's just his
his willingness to protect
uh this guy that he barely knew at the
attachment to him and then we really
didn't know in that first
episode when we saw him like what he
was was or what he was doing or was he
force sensitive we didn't know and then
just to see him be like yeah i can stop
like a whole ass mud [ __ ] and i was
like okay
he's got a lot of power you're my
argument
every moment ev every time groga is on
screen you get something michael smith
just commented that him drinking the
bone broth
is arguably one of the best oh yeah
that's some snark right there
sipping the tea so do you like the cute
moments do you like the
the bad ass man you like the giftable
moments it's really up to you
which is why we're here that is why
we're here and if you
agree with ash and you think that taking
down that what'd you say ash a whole ass
mudhorn horn is
the best moment for grosgu then hit that
like button or if you agree
with katelyn that whole trade that got
worked out
you hit that love button katelyn 30 more
seconds before the end of the round
there's not a wrong answer here for
grogu moments but
something about that gift that you can
use
of him rushing back with his little baby
feet like across the desert to
only be picked up by mando and be so
happy that he's back in his father's
arms
this is the point in the series when the
two of them have really really
started to connect you know for a fact
that
mando would do anything for this kid by
this point which wasn't in question at
all but it is solidified by little
moments like these
i'm looking at all these now everybody's
posting gifts of their favorite baby
yeah i love it the uh the accidental
electrocution
is another highlight for me yes
okay let me take y'all back both great
arguments i i don't it's probably gonna
be another neck and neck race here
if you just read it on the page as a
star wars fan are you concerned that
this is just going to
not come off well that is just going to
be cheesy or it's going to be some weird
play at selling toys like there was a
good chance that baby yoda just wouldn't
have
played like like it ended up doing
yeah i feel like this entire show is
like that there's so many moments where
i'm like
if you just wrote this down for me and
gave it to me you're like oh luke
skywalker's gonna come back and boba
fett's gonna come back he survived and
he's going to get his armor back and
cobb dancer and ahsoka's going to come
i'd be like oh my god what is this and
it just works so well i
constantly proven wrong by the show yeah
it's like
it could be fan service tm and yet it
still manages to ride that
line perfectly the number of people who
i have seen that like comment about that
about how it could be ridiculous
like the amount of stuff the way that we
are eating every single week when this
show is on
is absolutely ridiculous and even if
you're not
a huge star wars fan you can still enjoy
these little things even if you don't
really know who boba fett is or don't
really care
you at least know that he's important to
this context and so they are able to
just bring together
all different kinds of fans well boba
fett's name
could come up in this next round but
before we get to your most badass moment
we got to settle the score here you
click the like
for ash you click the love for caitlyn
and
caitlin bush has her first lead of the
ball game
it is two to one in favor of caitlyn
it was a whole ass mud horn but that
whole rope-a-dope with the rocket and
it's just taking off it's a little too
much weight
for groku so we are going to continue on
now with the fourth round okay ash you
get a win here and you force
overtime if not caitlyn bush is gonna
win today's
binge battle and like i said it's badass
moment so ash crossing why don't you
have the floor
what's the most badass moment in the
mandalorian oh man
again another hard one but for me the
idea of we were just talking about this
but the idea of boba fett
surviving the sarlacc pit was one of
those things i always like
liked but i never really knew if they
could pull it off in a way that didn't
feel ultra fan service-y and then
to see boba fett not only survive but
then there's the moment where
uh they're fighting in um outside of
california somewhere
in chapter 14 and they're on titan yeah
that's right typhon
and boba fett's doing his thing and we
kind of see him look over to the razor
crest
and you're like oh my god he's gonna get
the armor and then he has that moment
where he rises up over one of the storm
troopers in full armor and then just
i think kills about 40 stormtroopers in
this moment
in about 10 seconds so besides luke this
is the moment that elicited the biggest
reaction for me in the entire show and i
thought it was done
so well and it could have gone an
opposite direction but it was just
chef's kiss yeah and uh special
additional chef's kiss to our tech team
working hard behind the scenes and
showing you all this great mandalorian
food thank you
how quick and like badass that scene was
of
boba fett just wasting all these
stormtroopers the cautionary tale of
that is of course
hey kids take it from me you don't
necessarily want to matriculate in life
and then try to put on your old high
school basketball uniform because it may
not fit the way that you remember it
it's a little different but you got the
job done and now the job is yours
caitlyn what is the most badass moment
in the mandalorian
you know i did consider that boba moment
that was like one of my top things
but i had to take it to an actual
moment for denjarian it had to be
something in my mind that the
mandalorian himself performed
so i have to go back to the first
episode of season two
when when they're trying to defeat the
great dragon him and cobb band have no
idea what the heck they're doing they
come up with a last-second plan
bo uh mando grabs uh
like some bait pulls them over and then
puts himself inside of the crate dragon
and blows it up from the inside out in
like a perfect
like disney's hercules moment where he
blows it apart
and then of course you know you get the
the tuscan raiders with the
with the pearl and all the aftermath
there but the moment
that that dragon blows up out of nowhere
and nando just lands
and cool guys don't look back at
explosions kind of moment it's just it's
glorious
yeah you know you said like a disney
fight moment and you got to think back
to
how nice of human beings or wooden boys
that geppetto and pinocchio were because
they didn't
they could have blown up monster of the
whale and just like killed the whale
but they're like now let's just make him
sneeze let's just give him a call and
he'll sneeze us out and we'll be and
everybody's going to walk away monstrous
swims happy
that's a binge battle for a different
day ash the focus is back
to your badass moment boba fett gets his
armor why is that
more badass than what we saw with the
mandalorian blowing up a giant animal
from the inside
look i think i love the great dragon
moment by the way but for boba fett i
think a lot of
fans felt this way of like why do people
love boba fett so much he kind of goes
down pretty quickly like i don't really
get why he's like a fan favorite
character for people
and this was a moment that i think
proved everyone who felt that way
absolutely wrong me being one of them
being like i like boba fett but like is
he as badass as everyone says
yes he absolutely is it worked so well
and this is also one of those moments
where if you're gonna bring back boba
fett
you gotta do it right and they executed
this perfectly
robert reverence shout out very well
said yeah they they executed it so well
we got the tease of boba fett at the
very end of the first
episode of this new season two and
you're just wondering okay so this is
gonna be like this
hermit like an obi-wan stumbling around
the desert in a new hope or are we gonna
get some action scenes
we got a lot more than just that so
you're clicking that like for ash's
argument if you think that caitlyn is
correct with her argument
for most badass moment hit that love
button and caitlyn you get 30 more
seconds
to describe it right now okay
so when talking about what makes this so
good it's because
mando is so good at improvising this is
just like the
the peak of him working as a bounty
hunter for years and years and years
this is just yet another reminder at the
top of
season two that this guy is not someone
that you want to mess with
this guy is here to protect his son
and to like complete all of the side
missions that everyone has bestowed upon
him this season
this is a perfect opener to that and it
just it it's
a literal explosion right at the top of
the season
and i'm seeing uh alex in the facebook
chat
saying that mando perfected the
superhero landing yeah he really nailed
it
he did that really was this
do you want the superhero landing or do
you want the superhero rise up like
that's
that's what this is coming down between
yeah you get the rise up with with ash
and you get the landing
with caitlyn it's it boba fett's been
watching those
i mean we could all take both of them
and i just i'm trying to think of any
boba fett moment that i that i wouldn't
want or that i thought
i thought all the boba fett stuff played
so well and obviously mandalorian it's
like every word is so precious in there
but you watch his actions he watches
improvisational ability and you say this
guy you just never count him out in a
fight
a lot like the guy who's going to be
playing quarterback for the tampa bay
buccaneers
this weekend i do i think that the
chiefs are the favorite yes but do i
think tom brady should never be
yes i do in kansas city so it's going to
be a thing here
there you go well it certainly is going
to be a thing here on binge
battle because ash crosston has won the
most badass moment
this is going great it is two to two
and anytime i do a show like this you
just you want everybody to get on the
scoreboard you know you want everybody
to have a good time
it's two to two you all have adjudicated
yourselves great as true
positive lights in the star wars
universe and now we go
to our overtime debate round this is a
good one there's a reason why we saved
it for this
who wields the dark
saber ash just tied it so caitlyn bush a
minute is on the clock
who's wielding that dark saver
ultimately it's going to be book 10.
um she if you are a fan of any of the
animated series whether it be cloners or
whether it be star wars rebels
you know the lengths that she has gone
to for this
uh it is her right at this point
granted she had it before she lost it
there was some stuff with maul
we all need to get into that right now
but
ultimately it will be her she is the
most capable person here
and the only other logical person right
now
might be mando but he doesn't want it
he just he he doesn't so why wouldn't it
be beau who has the experience who has
the family name who has the respect
along
upon mandalore it has to be her
has to be heard maybe not mandalorian or
ash crossing do you think differently
who in your mind is going to be wielding
the dark saber
okay i feel like we could talk about
this for an hour but obviously we have
to we have to have different
answers here so i'm very curious about
this debate so i think it's going to be
den like i think the next season is
going to be about den helping bogutan
restore
mandalore and we've kind of seen
throughout the show so far there's like
these different factions of mandalorians
with different beliefs about the code
and the helmets and so on and so forth
and so there's obviously this big divide
here and bogatan even like describes
uh the children of the watches like a
cult um and we kind of see den he's
trying to like toe the line a bit a
little bit even like mayfield tells them
your rules change the more desperate you
get
so i think as much as i'd like for it to
be bogatan and it makes sense right now
i
think and it is just a symbol it's not
really like the keys to the kingdom or
anything
i think mando and the show being called
the mandalorian
is leading to this because i think he's
the one that's going to be able to
reunite is to like unite
everybody and i have to imagine that's
where it's going but i can be totally
off
okay so we're just we have all these
different uh
sects of the same belief system and
they're all splintered off and maybe
that is the symbol and mando's the
person to unite them or bo catan
certainly the next in line so to speak
so more medieval times you're probably
going bokeh tan for sure
if you think ash is correct with the
mandalorian guest then you are going to
hit that
like button if you think that caitlyn
has the lockdown on bo katan then you
hit that love
button and caitlyn 30 more seconds
why do you think that it's not gonna be
ash's choice of ultimately being mando
i think while amanda will obviously get
sucked into this larger scheme in the
universe that he never planned
on doing like boba said he is similar
he's a simple man trying to make his way
in the universe
he will get sucked into this but
ultimately he does not want that
responsibility i think he's on a journey
to break his
his weird cult conditioning that he had
at one point
um he probably might end up as an
advisor to boca tan down the line
but ultimately she's the lady with all
of the answers
she's the one who who knows this world
that mando is kind of just taking larger
steps into for the first time
so experience over popularity i have to
go with experience
i watch this show and i ne multiple
times and i never got as deep with the
mandalorian war and thinking about the
mythology of it as y'all are presenting
right now so
i'm i'm here for more of it again love
for kaitlyn like for ash ash
30 more seconds of defending mandalorian
and illuminating me to this belief
system
i don't it's so complex and obviously
like we don't know where it's going if
we did we wouldn't be watching the show
um but i don't yeah i don't know i just
think the title is like i get really
hung up on that because i feel like him
being the mandalorian unless it's like
somebody else you know maybe it's
leading to that
um it just makes so much sense to me i
don't know how exactly they're going to
do it because i obviously don't want to
see boko tan like
ousted or anything like that like she
obviously deserves it but i think just
in terms of the story
i just feel like it's going to be him i
don't know why yet though
very strong hunch and he's going to be
wrong
yeah or yeah it can go to grover maybe
it's grogu
maybe grogu is the mandalorian okay
that's my vote then then i'll say grogu
and we'll see
we're tabulating the votes right now
once again get those last votes in like
for ash
love for caitlyn that's a thumbs up for
ash that's the heart
for caitlyn season three we're gonna get
a season three we're very excited about
it
probably a lot less grogu though right
i mean are we gonna see gregory at all
in season three i mean i hope so but i
feel like we're we've we're done with
grogu for now they will be reunited
but i also occasionally just think about
how
groggy was going to learn luke
skywalker's name and the last time that
he heard the name skywalker some really
bad stuff went down
uh so i feel like he's not gonna react
very well to that
oh and i wonder where we're going to be
in time because if we're getting the
book above that next year
i don't know if the mandalorian's going
to come back for a hot minute
um i would guess like mid next year late
next year
i hope so but like i wonder if they're
like let's put a pause on this work on
some other shows
then we'll come back and they'll be like
a time jump yeah i don't know
kenobi like you said we got bad batch
like there's there's so much we got
cassie and andor
we got there's so much happening y'all
there's a lot there's a lot to get
excited about so grogu take your nap
mandalorian go
take a space mission sleep without your
helmet and don't let anybody see you for
a little bit
seeing boba fett sit down on that throne
that got me i'm like okay i'm juiced i'm
ready for the book of boba fett
how confusing was that they were like
book of boba fett and i was like is it a
book
is it a show is it is it is that what
the next i remember people were like is
that what the third season the
mandalorian is is that like the
mandalorian colon the book of boba fett
and they had to go
wait no sorry actually it's a whole
nother thing
we're so spoiled as fans not only do we
need post credit scenes and everything
now now we need them explained to us
yeah bring it down for me disney please
i am here to explain that the voting is
done the votes have been tabulated and
this
is one of the closest binge battles
we've ever had in the illustrious
history of this show
courtesy of rotten tomatoes and winning
the binge battle today
by the skin of their teeth is
the dark saber is being wielded by ash
crossing ladies and gentlemen
ash crossing wins she she took you to
overtime
caitlyn this was such a fun debate
to watch it was so cool to see you all
go back and forth and really convince me
and i didn't know which side i was going
to be voting on
i hope you all enjoyed yourself first of
all ash you won
so i'm sure you want to talk a lot of
trash to the internet right now
oh yeah like no no this was so fun and
um
you know it's like it's just fun talking
about mandalorian in like a positive way
it's just a lot of fun i love it i don't
know caitlyn you're awesome i like
i liked debating with you it was very
fun
very fun very fun hey i'm just
i'm i'm marking i'm just happy to be
invited yeah i'm honestly just happy to
to do something else while in quarantine
something new yeah
it is a nice way to gab and pass the
time so before we say good night to
everybody here these are two
of the most fantastic talented
personalities in the entire space you
can call it a nerd community and call it
star wars fans whatever you want to do
you're going to see caitlyn and ash
everywhere now that you know them if
this was your introduction to them
follow them wherever they are not in
real life that's creepy
do it online support their causes ash
you are a champion where can everybody
uh find you on social media since you're
a lot better at knowing your credits
than i am
what are you currently working on yeah
i'm so i'm not at access hollywood i am
an entertainer tonight so you can find
me on et online.com um but mostly if you
want to find my work just
ash carlson at ashcross and on twitter
that's where i post everything that i'm
doing so yeah follow me there and we'll
chat
and we're looking for streaming
recommendations because that that whole
currency thing it's not quite over that
pandemic yeah we're
we're trying to get to the finish line
here what's a good pick what's something
that we can watch
that that is gonna take our mind off of
the troubles of the real world
oh me first okay um i'm gonna go with
what we do in the shadows if you have
not watched the show
yet on hulu uh you absolutely need to
watch it's on fx but it's also on hulu
and also uh mark hamill makes an
appearance in it in arguably the best
episode of the show we can have another
binge battle about that if we'd like
uh with jackie daytona human bartender
but it's so
freaking funny so definitely check that
one out if you haven't yet it's a
must-watch
i've been thinking about this for months
and i just don't know that there's a
funnier name that you could have ever
picked for that
scene or for that show that episode than
jackie daytona it's
it's literally it's the perfect the
toothpick
she doesn't recognize him and mark
hamill's great in it too
uh caitlyn bush where can everybody find
it you're working on so much cool stuff
with sci-fi right now what's
what's the latest yeah man well we're
doing scifi.com right now
uh obviously ton of wanovision stuff we
are always here to talk about star wars
and also sci-fi has a new show called
resident alien with alan tudyk
who you know from firefly you know as
k2so
in star wars the man is a legend
absolutely adore him
uh but most if you want to actually get
in contact with me you can find me
mostly on twitter at
caitlyn m bush it's bush like the beer
not like the presidents
uh and otherwise i think oh a
streaming recommendation uh what do you
do in the shadows
wonderful show i have to pick voltron
legendary defender though the reboot
that they did
it's on netflix it's heartwarming and
funny and if you like star wars at all
you're going to enjoy this because it's
still just space except it's a bunch of
people flying around
in robot lions that combine like into an
ultron kind of
creator all right you had my curiosity
at robots you had my interest at robot
lions
so i might have to check out that
voltron thing
it's such a pleasure to connect with
both y'all thank y'all for joining us
today on binge battle and look
if you enjoyed the show today at all
please give a big virtual round of
applause wherever you are to our amazing
behind the scenes crew
here at rotten tomatoes if you say hey
kaitlyn and ashford great that host's so
mediocre the only reason i look as good
as mediocre is because of everybody
behind the scenes
so a big tip of the cap to them ash
kaitlyn
i am merely mark ellis whether you're
watching on facebook or on youtube
please make sure you check out
ryantomatos.com for
all the latest and their binge guide on
there is going to give you a bunch of
helpful tips
as to what to watch to suit your
lifestyle why we all get to
hang out at home with our pets way too
much and make sure you follow rotten
tomatoes
at rotten tomatoes on all social media
platforms and check out the rotten
tomatoes wrong podcast hosted by
this idiot and jacqueline coley so until
our next binge battle
for ash crossing and katelyn bush i'm
mark ellis saying so long
and may the force be with you
you